ja ich möchte es einfach mal teilen und
zwar bin ich der festen Überzeugung dass
wir aufhören sollen die Maske zu tragen
nicht nur weil ich finde es beim
aktuellen im Fragen und genesenen raten
es nicht mehr nötig ist sondern vor
allem auch der Umwelt zuliebe denn alle
sprechen ja immer darüber dass wir
aufhören sollen Fleisch zu essen wir
sollen nicht mehr Auto fahren aber auch
das Maske tragen ist nicht gut für
unsere Umwelt ein Beispiel
die Maske wenn man mit einem VW Diesel
einen halben Kilometer fährt hat man
genauso viel CO2 ausgestoßen wie wenn
man die Maske einmal trägt und da wir
alle fast nur noch einwegmasken tragen
also die op-masken und die ffp2-masken
ist also pro maskengebrauch ein halber
Kilometer mit einem VW Diesel in beiden
Fällen sind das 50 Gramm dazu kommen
noch das recyclingproblem ich meine das
jetzt hier natürlich schon mit einem
Augenzwinkern aber ich bin dafür weg mit
der Maske der Umwelt